c'est notre premier invité de tout ton
poste pour les siens c'est incroyable
professeur à hook est prêt est ce que le
professeur
a
bien sûr fait sa roue ne va pas débattre
à y joue comme il aime le dire c'est
vraiment voilà on va lui demander on va
on s'est vraiment une interview du
professeur
bonsoir
[Rires]
et ma femme ma femme est psychiatre elle
parle avec les femmes donc si vous
voulez vous est génial comme ça vous
prenez un rendez vous chez elle
[Applaudissements]
chez nous la cote chez nous s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît on va accueillir
le professeur à ou bonsoir professeur à
vous merci d'être avec nous ce soir
merci beaucoup bonsoir merci par les
mots avec respect sans insulter sans
vous exciter et pas des mouvements vous
inquiétez pas en arrière
bien sûr tout va bien se passer un
professeur vraiment on est très content
de dire merci en tout cas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et apparemment
il veut pas trop parler avec vous
professeur à ou déjà première question
comment ça va parce qu'il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses c'est vrai que depuis
deux ans il se passe plein de choses
autour de vous au moins je
pourrai vous allez bien de vous
inquiéter pas très bon je vais très bien
écoute je suis une espèce de caricatures
de de ce qui se passe dans ce pays c'est
à dire on a soigné de gens que n'importe
qui dans un astur monde on a publié bien
sûr plus de papier que tous les français
on en est à 112 publications
internationales sur le combiné donc on
nous envoie quelqu'un à paris pour nous
dire écoutez c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire arrêter tout donc je trouve
que c'est une espèce de splendeur de de
la deûle à l'évolution de ce pays qui
trouve que quand quelque chose marche
trop bien il faut l'arrêter ce jeu
professeur iront à titre personnel c'est
très bien professeur vous souhaitez pas
qu'il ya une espèce de de jalousie
autour de vous vraiment que les gens ont
été jaloux parce que vous avez été trop
mise en avant vous étiez devenu une star
en deux ans c'est vrai que vous êtes un
des personnages français les plus connus
les plus célèbres les les plus
controversés les plus commentés est-ce
que c'est pas une sorte de jalousie
français ça
ça fait partie de ces la france est long
duel entre la détestation c'est de ces
élites et l'amour de l'élite c'est se
payer comme ça je le dis souvent on a eu
saint-just et napoléon dans la suite
s'agissait à l'époque de la révolution
on a tué le plus grands scientifiques
français le plus grand juriste penser le
plus grand poète français et puis après
on a recréé et dès qu'on dira ces cycles
de la france c'est comme ça professeur
on vous sent à chaque foi inébranlable
ce qui s'est passé avec avec lee a chu
puisque
voilà vous serez plus professeur
université on l'a vu il ya quelques
quelques temps et plus plusieurs des
membres de l'ihh h eu envie de tourner
la page raoult comme ils disent est ce
que ça vous a peiné ou est-ce que
franchement ça vous passe au dessus
non non non vous en clair s'il vous
plaît il ya un directeur général qui est
le directeur général adjoint de prix qui
est venu ici et qui a pensé qu' il n'a
besoin de mes services au chu ce qu'il a
bien droit de penser maintenant il a une
opinion sur l'île il ya une opinion sur
liège il rêve un peu aussi pente peut il
est capable aux et ça parce que et
hachez créée par une loi tiens conseil
d'administration auquel il ya vingt
personnes qui s'expriment et ont fait
pas de push sur une sur une fonction de
cette nature là donc il faut se calmer
il faut pas je pense que dans ce pays et
j'ai entendu lier port quelques minutes
il ya une une tendance alibris dire à la
démesure la déraison qui a exacerbé et
cette épique spectaculaire et d'autre
les gens s'imaginent mais enfin des gens
que j'ai j'ai pu passer kit imaginer
qu'ils allaient dicter leur loi puis 30
ans j'en ai vu que a survécu très
facilement vous avez vu des manifestants
moi je serais plus inquiet pour le dg si
vous venez à marquer je serais plus
inquiet pour lui que l'on a fait c'est
d'accord doit être fier content c'est
lui duris calmer parce que les
marseillais sont allés chez tt un quart
de la population marseillaise ouais
j'ai vu on a vu encore dans les
manifestations ce week-end beaucoup de
gens qui vous soutiennent avec un touché
par how ça vous touche ce genre de
liesse populaire autour de vous et de
vos dons de soutien
écoutez moi je dis seulement mon vieux
maître me disais je préfère dans les
compliments aux fesses je suis d'accord
avec lui mais on est d'accord moi aussi
donc si
donc que si les gens disent du bien de
moi je suis content voilà je leur
demande pas ni d'où ils viennent ni du
coup c'est que ce soir et à le syndicat
sud qui me soutient d'un côté philippe
au de l'autre ça m'est égal je suis
content moi mes idées politiques que
j'ai pas vous les donne et je vous
assure pour qui je vote jamais dit pour
qui j'ai voté et puis voilà c'est pas
mon problème moi je fais de la science
c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est le soir
de me regarder à mon miroir en n'ayant
pas honte de moi voilà donc je fais pas
de propagande non plus justement votre
politique je fais pas de faux pas des
hommes politiques c'est une une des
causes de mon désaccord avec le
directeur général c'est que voulait
faire signer une tribune qui me paraît
de la propagande que je veux pas faire
parce que je sais c'est pas mon rôle
donc mon rôle c'est pas de dire que le
gouvernement fait bien ou pas bien mon
rôle c'est de dire ce que j'observe de
ce que je lis
compte tenu de ce que
mon parcours voilà justement professeur
à vous parler il ya deux petites
secondes de politique quels sont vos
rapports avec olive et veyran parce
qu'on avait vu une pub voilà parodique
pour rtl qui disait revivre ensemble
quels sont vos rapports parce qu'on a
toujours dit que voilà c'était assez
compliqué ils n'hésitent pas à vous
brocardé un petit peu dans certaines
interviews certaines sorties dans la
presse
tant qu'elles sont vos relations
aujourd'hui
j'ai eu
pour l'instant écouté il y avait à voir
un de ses conseillers et puis je
m'entendais très bien que j'appelais une
fois par semaine avant de faire mon
monde émissions de manière à ce qu'ils
soient pas surpris il est parti il n'a
pas été remplacé par quelqu'un avec qui
je peux parler donc je leur parle pas
quand à ce que dit le ministre
honnêtement je vais vous dire la vérité
je ne regarde jamais la télévision je
n'écoute pas la radio je dis pas les
journaux alors je n'en sais rien vous
savez qui je suis
écoutez j'ai entendu votre nom mais je
connais à peine votre tête j'ai jamais
vu mon nom est plus beaux spas tête vous
savez le meilleur professeur et avec
avec emmanuel macron le président ça me
fait plaisir de vous faire rire avec le
président mâcon ont dit on dit qui vous
appelez beaucoup avant
est-ce que vous avez encore de sénou ce
que c'est vrai qu'il a il a beaucoup
pris conseil auprès de vous au début de
la crise notamment comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui
écoutez j'essaie de lui faire passer des
messages que je considère comme étant
essentielle pour le pays c'est ça
d'accord il les a écouté ses messages
vous a lâché à vue
écoutez
je vous ai dit la politique je considère
que c'est très compliqué que ce n'est
pas mon métier de toute manière c'est
pour ça que veron est ce qu'il est le
président fait ce qui peut de toute
manière je voudrais pas être à leur
place parce que c'est pas mon métier
chez pas le faire c'est multifactoriel
ya des influences multiples il ya des
conditions y compris que je ne connais
pas et donc je ne me mêle pas la
politique c'est l'histoire qui la jugent
la science il faut un peu de temps ça se
fait pas sur un plateau de télé sur un
peu de temps pour savoir ce qui est vrai
et ce qui est pas vrai donc je je je
conseille aux gens qui interviennent
d'être prudent dans ce qu il conclu dans
l'immédiat parce que la vie est
malicieuse les maladies infectieuses
sont des maladies d'écosystèmes variable
on connaît pas tous les éléments
dangereux mais tu entends je suis
surpris de l'ignorance totale j'ai été
frappé par exemple de l'ignorance totale
de la virologie dans ce pays a rapporté
puisque les gens ne savaient pas que les
virus à arn muté moi comme si on était
les premiers au monde va trouver des
variants pas ce que je fais la génétique
microbienne depuis 21 ans et les gens
disent en public et fasse dire au
ministre le conseil scientifique disent
y'a pas de mutants ya pas de variantes
dans des virus à elle mais c'est une
bêtise mois janssen 100 étudiants en
première année en fin de soirée
une facilité à donner ses opinions qui
sont étonnantes quand on a des
connaissances qui sont au lit aussi
limité de scientifiques de base de base
d'études de bêtises mais tous les gens
qui ont fait des études de médecine
vient pour longtemps ne savent pas ce
qu'ils est ce qu'on va découverte depuis
c'est très intéressant professeur à
aujourd'hui quand vous voyez ce qui se
passe dans le monde qu est ce qui se
passe autour du vaccin quand vous voyez
ce qui se passe en israël conviés ce qui
se passe en france est-ce qu'on a des
raisons d'être optimiste ou est-ce qu'on
doit être inquiet
écoutez je sais que j'ai jamais produit
à venir ce que ce que j'ai dit est ce
que je veux je maintiens est-ce que ce
sur quoi je suis consistant parce que je
je connais les infections respiratoires
c'est pas la première quand même c'est
que le vaccin contribuer à une
protection d'une partie de la population
que le vaccin soit une baguette magique
dans une infection respiratoire ça
serait une nouveauté donc je n'ai pas
été surpris ça ne soit pas qu'ils
puisaient pour les vaccins rn2 de virus
à arn qui sont toujours d'une difficulté
extrême du fait de leur variabilité donc
moi je suis pas du tout surpris par
l'évolution je les fais je suggère de
regarder dans cette petite vidéo pour
expliquer les la succession des variants
et bien entendu comme c'est la
globalisation les pays qui sont au
centre de la globalisation c'est au
milieu des voyages sont plus sont le
plus exposées à ces variants successifs
ce dont on a l'impression la différence
de ce que j'ai entendu ici nous quand on
mesure pour l'instant à la la gravité le
ratio d'hospitalisation et on est un des
rares endroits à pouvoir le faire du
dernier variant indien qui a été
rebaptisé delta le taux
d'hospitalisation et plus bas celui qui
a été le plus élevé c'est celui que les
gens appellent alpha qui était en était
le premier grand variant panier nouveaux
variants épidémique que nous on appelle
marseille 4 qui avait le plus fort taux
d'hospitalisation le plus fort taux de
mortalité
quant à
celui qui est apparue en août et qui a
eu deux il ya eu un sou variante est
apparue en octobre qui est celui qui a
le plus est pour l'instant un
ensuite si vous voulez pour les vaccins
je sais pas c'est extrêmement complexe
nous on a une corps de 1600 vacciner on
n'a pas vu de différence de sévérité
significative entre les vacciner les non
vaccinés en fonction des différents
variant voile aura pas vu ça veut pas
dire que ça ne soit pas mais globalement
je me méfie des approximations et des
modèles et je suis je pense y ait des
données où il faut attendre de les avoir
observés et nous on voit bien que
l'observation de ce que nous avons vu
vraiment ce à dire qu'il ya vraiment 41
mille personnes qui ont été
diagnostiqués dans un tissu et 33000 ou
34000 qui ont été traitées qu'on l'a vue
pour rien là des dossiers on sait de
quoi on parle assez mais c'est pas des
études multicentriques à 20 en droit
dont on ne sait pas comment les dossiers
ont été remplies donc c'est
ça ce sont des données qui m'intéresse
de rapporter parce que ce sont des
données réelles et donc on verra bien le
temps passera mais il y a trop de
passion dans leurs rapports de ces
données il ya trop de gens qui
voudraient que ça marche pas du tout il
ya trop de gens qui dirait non non non
non il ya des cas mais c'est fade et
paca important moi j'ai dû rectifier
auprès du directeur général qui
racontait qu'il n'y avait que 1 % de
vaccinés parmi 23 hommes
éthique que j'ai appris ça en cinquième
un le seigneur est générale vous l'avez
dans le nez un professeur
non non c'est plutôt lui qui m'a donné
puis et puis cc je sais je suis un vieil
homme je vais être très dense paie donc
je j'ai du mal oui non vous êtes
magnifique la coiffure est magnifique
j'adore capillairement parlant moi je
j'adore j'adhère je n'ai
non non non je vous le dit maintenir sa
place si vous voulez
moi j'ai vu j'ai vu cet affolement parce
que lui et pas que lui un lui et mes
collègues de la cme faisait d un
pourcentage de 1% sur un nombre de
personnes qui ne permettaient pas de
dire qu'il ya pour ça on sait dire que
quand on a vingt ou quarante personnes
on peut pas avoir un pour cent ça alors
ça défie bois ma connaissance et çà et
là c'est bien avant des études de
médecine c'est quand j'étais tout petit
donc je vois bien 7,7 cette passion qui
s'y met dès que vous entendez j'ai une
nuance vous faites partie des antilles
vax cirque on a plus le droit de
réfléchir et donc dès qu'on dit vous
savez c'est plutôt moche et j'ai écrit
écouter les personnels de soins qui sont
au contact des malades le bénéfice est
plutôt plus important que le risque
légende qui risque de faire une forme
grave de co vide le bénéfice est plutôt
plus important que le risque c'est des
choses qui sont raisonnables
raisonnable aujourd'hui la peut dire la
politique sanitaire de la france pau
pour vous c'est la bonne aujourd'hui on
est on est on est sur le bon chemin on
fait des bonnes choses le pass
sanitaires tout ça pour vous cdc c'est
bien c'est ce qu'il fallait faire
vous savez c'est l'histoire qui
tranchera le lit les gens qui vous
disent qu'ils ont que c'est la pop la
seule politique faire ne regarde pas ce
qui se passe ailleurs par exemple il ya
des choses dont je pense que
scientifiquement elles sont pas
raisonnables c'est de dire que quelqu'un
qui a eu coville doit être vacciné deux
mois après alors ça ça n'a aucune base
scientifique on sait maintenant lorraine
ou moi ça je le sais on peut pas me
raconter d'histoires parce que j'ai
mesuré tel était le nombre de gens qui
rechute et dont il ya un taux de
protection de l'infection naturelle qui
est plus de 99% n'y a pas un vaccin au
monde qui fait ça donc de dire que
quelqu'un qui a fait un gros vide doit
être vacciné deux mois après c'est pas
de la science chez parce que c'est pas
de vous asseoir mais c'est pas vrai la
deuxième chose c'est quand on oblige -
ça m'ennuie chevet zafy africains qui
souvent sont fait vacciner par le vaccin
chinois et quand on leur dit voc va
c'est un chinois ça vaut rien c'est
comme si vous n'avez pas été vaccinés et
que l'on dit sert ici mais on dit pas ça
en finlande et en suède on peut pas dire
que c'est ta science non plus on disait
une opinion politique c'est notre
stratégie et les stratégies on verra à
la fin
mais si vous voulez ya des 2des qui sont
basées sur des données réelles
calme posé qui sont la connaissance
médicale et ya donné qu'ils ont des
choix qui ne sont pas compréhensibles au
vu de ce que l'on connaît scientifique
au vu de ce que l'on a vu faire dans les
pays qui pour l'instant le mieux géré la
clé
juste on entend beaucoup de choses et
c'est vrai que là on parle de troisième
dose maintenant de vaccins il ya aussi
de plus en plus de gens qui disent
écoutez je pense qu'on va être obligé de
se faire vacciner tous les six mois tous
les un an qu'on va devoir vivre à qu'on
va devoir vivre avec avec 7 c'était
cette pandémie aujourd'hui est-ce que
penser que c'est dangereux peut-être de
devoir se faire vacciner tous les six
mois c'est un petit peu la crainte voilà
de toutes les personnes qui se font
vacciner qui j'ai pas envie de me faire
vacciner non plus tous les six mois tous
les un an peut-être qu'il ya des
répercussions que j'aurai sur mon corps
qui vont être peut-être compliqué
derrière
ceux qu'on a vus mais qu'est ce qui
compliquait encore une fois parce qu'il
ya trop de passion plutôt que de n'y a
pas assez de connaissances et trop de
passion c'est que ces vaccins n'ont pas
du tout de la durée d'efficacité que les
uns et les autres pour espérer c'est ça
en réalité il ya une dégradation de leur
efficacité assez grande et comme en plus
de ça ils n'ont pas une efficacité aussi
bonnes sur les variants que sur la cible
primaire sur lequel il avait il y avait
ciblé bien entendu ça pose une question
de la la durée d'efficacité de la
vaccination donc moi si vous me posez la
question est-ce que ça a un sens chez
quelqu'un qui est à très haut risque à
dire les les obésité maladive des gens
qui pèse 150 kilos ou bien alors est ce
que il faut vacciner les gens qui ont
plus de 70 ans qui en plus des
pathologies associées est ce qu'il faut
faire une troisième dose ça me chante
pas du tout se sait je trouve
lequel on pensait on va avoir un pique
nique ce donc
on est passé sur canal + il est en
crypté le réseau raoul 12 ans non ça ça
va ça va se décanter un sérieux on va on
va régler ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
très intéressant parce que des
professeurs donc c'est vrai qu'on
aimerait bien avoir la fin on a eu des
petits soucis de son professeur à où
est-ce que vous mourrez entendez bien
bon bah super bowl à nous on a eu des
petits soucis
professeur à aujourd'hui où vous est ce
que vous pouvez voilà quand voilà on
parlait de bénéfice/risque de bénéfice
risque aujourd'hui une personne qui est
plutôt jeunes qui à 35 ans qui en bonne
santé et qui dit on entend plein de gens
qui lisent moi j'ai pas envie de me
faire vacciner je vais pas prendre le
risque de me faire vacciner parce que
tout va bien pour moi je suis en bonne
santé et j'ai pas envie d'injecter
quelque chose dans mon corps voilà qui
qui qui me fait peur et qui devait peut
voir peut-être m'injecter tous les six
mois qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
gens là
encore une fois il ya deux choses là
aussi de ce que je veux bien séparées
dans votre esprit ce qui est la loi moi
je sais pas moi a décidé loi une fois
que la loi est faite moi je vais pas
vous dire de désobéir à la loi je les ai
jamais fait c'est ça c'est c'est je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le fait je passe
dix tenir un discours de désobéissance à
la loi donc si la loi vous oblige à
faire ça c'est la responsabilité des
gens qui font la loi et si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord vous n'avez qu'à demander à
votre député de most voté une motion de
censure que soul et que vous dites donc
la loi c'est la loi pour ça il ya un
exercice qui est l'exercice des
démocraties pour dans lesquels on vote
dans lesquelles les gens s'expriment moi
je vous parle de mes connaissances
scientifiques et éventuellement je peux
vous parler de ce que je lis de vous
vous votre avis est ce que vous auriez
fait au pays vous si un patient vient
vous voir de professeurs on vous dit
voilà j'ai 35 ans je qu'entends je suis
en bonne santé est-ce que je dois me
faire vacciner au pacs cloud l'unita or
là on parle pas de loi si vraiment voilà
il n'y avait pas cette loi qui était
tombé qu'est ce que vous lui diriez non
mais si six patients me pas aux deux de
la minute où il me parle je suis couvert
par le secret professionnel et je veux
pas vous emparer ouais mais c'est un
patient imaginaire donc vous pouvez nous
lire
bah oui
je le veux je ne je ne vous dirai pas ça
je vous ai dit je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de questions sur les patients qui
présentent un profil d'expert exposition
aux valeurs ni de questions sur les gens
qui risque et on sait très bien qu'ils
mèneront les dernières données de
l'insee sont sortis on sait bien
exactement ce qui s'est passé pendant
toute la première des premiers six mois
de l'année 2021 ces gens qui ont plus de
65 ans qui meurent et les gens qui ont
des pathologies lourdes soient des
cancers évolutive soit d obésité
maladive c'est toujours les mêmes ceux
là moi personnellement si vous me
demandez ce qui est une mesure de santé
publique c'est cela d'aller les chercher
d'accord voilà parce qu'en réalité
effectivement dans l'airé à et dans les
morts il y avait des gens qui n'étaient
pas vaccinés mais qui aurait dû être
vaccinés donc la question c'est est ce
que nous avons eu une bonne politique
vaccinale c'est à dire est ce que nous
sommes allés chercher les gens qui
devaient être vaccinés et qui devrait
probablement être vaccinés parce que ça
diminuerait symptômes ça c'est une
politique active et c'est pas une
politique moins de temps en temps j'ai
l'impression que la politique ça
ressemble plus à des jeux vidéo si vous
voulez on appuie sur le bouton oui non
on vaccine tout en vacs sinon moi je
crois à la verge je crois la médecine
mais si je pense qu'il faut soigner les
malades je pense vous regardez
d'ailleurs dans les meilleurs résultats
dans le covering c'est là la médecine
déplacer c'est à dire
je sais pas cuba s'est quand même pas un
miracle sur le plan de la technologie
mais ils ont des médecins qui vont voir
les gens ils vont des médecins qui l'ont
soigné les gens et ici les gens qui ont
besoin d'une attention particulière et
donc ça c'est la médecine revient la
médecine qui est personnalisée c'est à
dire la médecine des on pouvait espérer
tous les espoirs sont permis on pouvait
espérer qu'avec ce vaccin on aurait un
rôle pour bloquer les épidémies
maintenant il faut être un peu réaliste
les pays qui ont le mieux vacciner on a
vu des explosions épidémique comme les
autres jeux partout melzer niveau cmn et
vous avez maintenant d'israël je
montrerai ça un papier d'enseignants ce
qui est sorti c'est pas mickey ni le
monde c'est un vrai journal qui dit
écoutez maintenant ça suffit on dit ça
elle est à 80% des des gens qui sont
hospitalisés qui ont plus de 65 ans et
60% qui ont été vaccinés deux fois ça va
c'est que on n'arrête pas l'épidémie
avec sa donc la priorité c'est
d'empêcher les gens mourir et faire les
formes graves et ensuite l'évolution des
maladies infectieuses en particulier
mais l'évolution des maladies
infectieuses virales avec ses
rebondissements on connaît avec la
grippe il est récent ben laden- honda
des données préliminaires qui monte il y
avait du coc vide 19 au 19e siècle le
professeur des préliminaires on a
présenté avec dans la mine celle de
recours écoutez ces épidémies là sont
des épidémies successives nous on a
plutôt l'impression que la gravité
diminue au fur et à mesure et on va s'en
sortir professeur à oopa ou vers le ciel
de variation avec des variants
pathologique cas ce virus n'est pas plus
que tous les autres la différence c'est
que je suis que je suis né en depuis
début juste professeur house sera une
deuxième et dernière question ce qu'on a
ce qu'on va s'en sortir ou est ce que
voit toujours voir arriver un nouveau
variant qui va pouvoir juguler le vaccin
qu'est ce qu'on va vivre avec ça pendant
encore des années ou est ce qu'à un
moment on n'entendra plus parler du coc
vie de 19
écoutez je encore une fois vous reposer
les questions pour pour savoir si je
suis capable de prédire l'avenir je suis
pas capable de prévenir l'avenir moi je
crois à la besogne un jeu je crois que
il faut il faut essayer de ne pas se
disputer deux pas s'exciter face à adam
g il faut se battre c'est compliqué
c'est long c'est comme pour ça je suis
d'accord avec le président c'est comme
une guerre mais souvenez vous mais il
avait gagné la guerre mondiale elle a
duré très longtemps c'est la première
guerre mondiale ça dure très longtemps
faut pas se décourager il faut pas
s'énerver il faut pas se menacer il faut
pas s'exciter il faut pas virer les gens
parce qu'ils disent des choses qui vous
outil qui vous qui ne sont pas la
propagande c'est pas bien il faut
essayer de garder les meilleurs force il
faut essayer de retrouver la médecine on
peut pas faire de la médecine maintenant
en abandonnant le soin en disant il faut
plus soigner les malades on peut pas
abandonner la médecine en dix ans
maintenant on abandonne le secret
professionnel il faut pas le faire donc
c'est une longue bataille c'est pas la
border bataille que les mails et que les
humains et leurs médecins ont eu contre
les épidémies vous savez ans soigné à
marseille ont soigné la peste et quand
les gens on a des textes nous qu'on a ré
analysé du xviiie siècle et quand les
gens étaient soignés par des médecins
pour la paix ce prêt grosse aimant leur
espérance de vie n'était pas la main
mais pourtant on n'avait pas les
antibiotiques qui soit de la peste donc
il faut revenir à des notions basiques
il faut soigner les malades il faut
identifier les populations à risque il
faut se concentrer dessus en pratique il
faut faire de la médecine il faut pas
faire de la médecine par ordinateur il
faut faire de la nuit sur la médecine de
plateaux télé il faut faire de la vraie
médecine merci professeur a offert du
soin il faut faire de la prévention
personnalisée professeurs avant de vous
libérer qu'est ce que je peux vous
souhaitez professeur
parfois continuer à vivre en bonne santé
le mieux possible et le plus longtemps
moi je vais très bien en tout cas je
m'avoue voilà je suis sérieux mais je
m'amuse beaucoup merci merci en tout cas
professeur avouer mon père vous aime
beaucoup ça peut vous aider voilà
c'est important
[Applaudissements]